hi guys welcome back to simply learn in
our previous video we learned about
react.js components in detail and now
moving ahead let's learn about another
striking feature of react.js called
props props short for properties allow
the user to pass arguments or data to
components a parent component can pass
additional information to its children
using props properties help me
components more dynamic props are passed
to components in the ways similar to
that of HTML track attributes now we
look at this a little later in the video
props in a company are read-only and
cannot be changed one thing to remember
is that props are sent by the parent to
the children components hence the
children components cannot meet any
changes to these props now that we've
learnt about props in brief let's go
ahead and create our application using
props if you new to this tutorial I
suggest you go to the react installation
and react components video on our
channel so back in my code editor that
is vs code I've opened a folder called
react flops and now I'm going to create
a component a class component and I'll
call it class props dot Jas so let's
create the class component
I give RC e the snippet and here I
display a message saying an h1 tag
basically all right now let me get rid
of export here and import it in my apt
ojs main component here I say import
class props alright now we define the
class component in a render method
[Music]
all right now if you go back to the
browser
you see hello Lana's welcome to simply
Yan now let's say we want to
individually welcome every student
instead of retyping the message for
everybody we can pass their names as
props now let's see how to do that now
we pass the name as a property from the
main component that is apt objects to
the child component and render this on
to the browser so let's do that so here
while I'm defining my child component a
same name
I see it and here in my child component
instead of learner's I see I use a
keyword this dot drops dot name let me
save it and if you look at the browser
will have hello Lana one welcome to
simply lon
now let's go ahead and welcome 102 and
103 so I again say class drops name
equals Lana 2
all right so if we save and look at the
browser we'll have all the three
learners displayed on the browser we can
also pass multiple props to the child
component now say for example we want is
welcome the student from a particular
place so we say welcome Lana one from
place X so I can here define another
property say please and say please
similarly I can do it for the rest to
say this why
now let's go back to our class prop
storages component and here say hello
101 from this store props dot place let
me save it and if you look at the
browser now we have hello and a one from
place x place Y and place that we can
also display whatever we want between
the opening and closing tags when
invoking a component now this is
facilitated using prop store children
reserved keyword now let me explain to
you how it's done with an example here
let's split the self and closing tag
into an opening and closing tag and in
between them let me display a message
within the paragraph tag
let me save
and in my child component after my h1
tag let me use a barrel of tag and here
let's use the reserved keyword this dot
drops top children so let's save it and
now if you look at the browser you can
here see the message displayed child
component so prop stop children can be
used when components do not know about
their children ahead of time this is
commonly seen in components like sidebar
and dialogue that we present generic
boxes so let's go ahead and create a
button tag and check again
so here I'll split it and add a button
tag and say to click and let's check our
browser here we go we get the output as
expected all right
we saw the usage of props for class
components similarly we can use it for
functional components so let's go ahead
and create a functional component let me
call it
I say import react from react and then I
say function function props and here I
return an h3 tag I say this is
functional component and I'll return
another h3 tag sing hello learner so let
me save this and let's export it export
default function props and import it in
our apt ojs again import function drop
from function problem and here in our
render method let's define it
let me call function flop name
let me give Lana 4 and place
please see it let me close it and back
in a functional component instead of
learner I save props
dot name let me save it now if you look
at a browser
it gives us an arrow it says props is
not defined so let's go back to our core
editor and pass props here to our
functional component also let me define
hello prop start name from props dot
please lemme enclose it within the div
tag here let me save it and now if we
look at a browser here we go we get the
output as expected with this we've
reached the end of the video in our
upcoming video you learn more about
props and how they're used so watch out
for that until then keep learning and
stay tuned to simply yon hi there if you
like this video subscribe to the simple
learn youtube channel and click here to
watch similar videos turner up and get
certified
click here